this is maruthius from norway and i've
got a peeve
people in their 20s on social media
acting like they're self-help gurus all
of a sudden with these quotes and what
the [ __ ] telling me how to live my life
you don't even got your [ __ ] together
and you're just repeating stuff you
found on the internet it's unoriginal
and it's passive aggressive so yeah suck
my balls yeah
this guy's great guys that was not only
was that guy great but he nailed it like
he nailed it the only self-help [ __ ] i
want to see from a [ __ ] 20 something
is is an inspirational quote i don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm doing sign me
that's all i want to see yeah and he's
drinking in the video which i love and
he's spiraling in his
his apartment with a spiral staircase
behind him and he's in norway
did you hear that oh yeah
what was the name matt
maruthius marufius wow the dutch version
of morpheus in the matrix yeah
that's the guy that did the drawing of
uh the mark thick
the little video i loved it oh yeah that
was fun yeah he was great this guy's
this guy's a mvp
love more roofious love you maroof more
and more rupees i would i would say your
name very quickly that would have bar to
a woman
what was that less that's more
less roofies what role do you think our
childhood plays on this [ __ ] where
you're like where you're like well i
liked it when i was eight so i still
like it at a loyal true it's like
that what else the goonies the movie the
goonies yeah it's not that great no but
i still love it if you saw that when you
were 37 you go hey what is what are
these kids doing
but as a kid you're like oh my god sloth
data
he's asian had a father trying to get a
kid on board like come on there's some
good stuff
[Laughter]
one-eyed willy that's what you whip out
[Laughter]
that was that was strong thank you
there's more to see guys join the
patreon right now at patreon.com we
might be drunk get on the after party i
think i just broke this
there you go
you get emails tell us your wrecks your
jokes your drinks we'll open boxes
you're missing out folks all the good
stuff's on the patreon tell a friend